[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
cleveland browns quarterback desean
watson is suspended for six games after
sexual assault allegations surface and
week two of the sandy hook civil trial
after experiencing that out in the world
do neil and scarlet withdraw from
society to extend out tremendously
neil both of them pulled away from
people tremendously how experts say the
comments of conspiracy theorist alex
jones impacted one victim's family plus
a missouri judge hands down a mostly not
guilty verdict weeks after the murder
trial of rebecca rood and later a
youtube search for virginia tech
massacre was conducted ar15 google
search columbine diary youtube search
with the parkland school shooter
researched just days before the massacre
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm your host mike sacks in for brian
buckmeyer cleveland browns quarterback
deshaun watson will be suspended for six
nfl games according to espn this comes
after more than 20 female massage
therapists accuse watson of sexual
assault
disciplinary officer and former federal
judge sue robinson ruled watson violated
the nfl's personal conduct policy
according to espn the outlet also
reports robinson says there was not
enough evidence to justify a longer
suspension and that watson will not be
fined robinson heard arguments from the
nfl players union and watson's attorneys
back in june the nfl pushed for a
suspension of at least one year while
the union and watson's attorneys called
for no suspension at all from here
watson's camp could file an appeal
within three days but nfl commissioner
roger goodell would make the final
ruling watson's sexual assault
accusations date back to march 2020 when
he played for the houston texans 25
lawsuits were initially brought on by
women who claimed watson had
inappropriate conduct during massage
sessions in june watson settled 20 of
the 24 lawsuits he was facing this week
he settled three more joining us today
is co-host terry austin and law
professor and former detective kirk
burkhalter now kirk some critics are
calling the six game suspension a joke
especially when you take into account
calvin ridley's season band for placing
a 1500 bet is six games enough
well it's not just the six games so the
cleveland browns structured desean
watson's uh current contract in
anticipation that he would be penalized
so basically he's going to lose
333 000 however he will still collect
his over 200 million
dollar guaranteed salary so they
structured his uh contract so it would
be back loaded so even if the suspension
was for a year he wouldn't have lost
much so here the rub is really how this
entire thing was structured and that
what is is what probably is not going to
sit right with many folks the fact that
there's really no financial penalty here
yeah and terry watson settled most of
the lawsuits against him already so do
you think we'll ever see the terms of
those agreements
you know i think we will never see that
they did sign non-disclosure agreements
24 of the women who sued were
represented by the same plaintiff's
attorney and he basically is claiming
that the football team actually gave
those women the non-disclosure
agreements and he brought the football
team into the lawsuit and so he's
claiming that they were part and parcel
of everything that happened he also is
claiming on behalf of these individuals
that the
texas team actually paid for the hotel
where the massages occurred so he's
saying that these women were treated
poorly obviously and that the team was
well aware of what was going on i think
that it was probably a large settlement
we won't know that because of these ndas
but i bet you that he sued the team
because they are the ones who really
have eight pockets yeah and again roger
goodell will make the final judgment
here the final call and of course there
is room for appeal within three days now
i do want to move west to outside
chicago where the suspect in the
highland park fourth of july mass
shooting robert cremo the third is
indicted on 117 felony charges on
independence day cremo allegedly shot
into the crowd during a parade killing
seven people and wounding dozens of
others he was arrested several hours
after the shooting during a traffic stop
police say he admitted to emptying two
30-round magazines before reloading and
firing again
investigators say he shot 83 times from
a nearby rooftop with an ar style rifle
the alleged gunman is charged with 21
counts of first-degree murder three for
each victim he also faces 48 counts of
attempted murder and 48 more counts of
aggravated battery with a firearm
cremo is scheduled to appear in court
for his arraignment on wednesday if
convicted on the first degree murder
charges cremo faces a possible sentence
of life in prison and in texas newly
released body camera and surveillance
footage shows the moments leading up to
a deadly officer-involved shooting it
happened on july 29th outside of a
dallas convenience store officials say
the man 30-year-old kyle dial was
selling drugs near the store
dale drove off undercover officers
followed they say he then refused to
pull over making after making a traffic
violation now after an hour later dale
was back at the convenience store three
officers responded and later reported
that dale raised a gun in the air as
they attempted to take him into custody
when dale threw the weapon an officer
fired dale was unresponsive and
pronounced dead the following day
i'm not moving
okay i'm not moving give him your hands
[Applause]
right now the incident is under two
separate investigations by the dallas
police special investigations unit and
the dallas county district attorney's
office now still ahead on crime daily
weeks after missouri trials concludes a
verdict is finally handed down for
rebecca rood
but first the alex jones defamation
trial could a recent bankruptcy filing
affect the austin trial that's ahead
online prime daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
conspiracy theorist alex jones put his
infowars parent company into bankruptcy
amid the sandy hook school shooting
civil trial in texas in december 2012 a
gunman killed 20 first grade students
and six staff members at the connecticut
school after the shooting jones told his
audience it was a hoax and staged with
actors in order to push gun control the
families of several victims and an fbi
agent who responded to the incident
filed lawsuits against the political
conspiracy theorist over his comments
jones later said he believes the
shooting did happen but claims he had a
right to say that it didn't courts in
both texas and connecticut found jones
liable for defamation entering default
judgments against him saying he ignored
several court orders and failed to
respond to discovery demands juries will
now determine what he will pay in
damages on friday jones media company
free speech systems filed for bankruptcy
as the victim's family seeks 150 million
dollars in damages in the texas case the
plaintiffs who are the parents of sandy
hook victim jesse lewis are expected to
testify this week so far jurors have
heard from several witnesses including
infowars employees and investigators on
monday a forensic psychiatrist took the
stand testifying lewis's parents were
affected mentally after jones comments
when a person deals with a traumatic
event and is suffering from ptsd
that stems from a person influencing
that larger number of people
what does that do to the severity of
what neil and scarlet are feeling inside
let me be
great deal of anxiety it creates terror
and we see that in the
things they've said to me and the
precautions that i mostly talked about
more with scarlet we're having a gun and
knife and pepper spray and
a
big alarm system not even being willing
to use the air conditioner despite how
hot it is this summer in all of those
things that she does every single day of
her life none of them
have to do with the death the murder of
jesse correct no they don't they all
have to do
for they all stem from what alex jones
did to him yes
from alex jones starting people up
and
then people
believing him and believing that they're
lying
psychiatrists there saying trauma upon
trauma now terry jones has defaulted in
both connecticut and texas so
consequently he cannot defend his claim
but what would have been his argument
well he is claiming obviously freedom of
speech freedom of the press under the
first amendment but that doesn't
guarantee you the right to say anything
and obviously it doesn't protect you
against defamation and all he has to you
know do is tell the truth and be
diligent in reporting what is correct so
he absolutely was reckless here and
that's one of the standards as far as
defamation is concerned it was either
knowingly or recklessly published and
that it caused injury that's why you saw
those individuals testifying about the
injury that it caused and he could have
argued those defenses but he didn't he
just defaulted on the judgments and now
he's actually claimed bankruptcy for the
company and the judge ruled go ahead
anyway the suit can continue even though
that's unusual and i think that that was
the right thing to do the prosecution
basically said this was a vile campaign
of defamation remember this is just one
of three civil suits for which judgments
is being are being considered against
him now kirk how could this bankruptcy
filing affect this defamation trial or
any of jones's future litigation
kirk looks like you might be frozen
there but i do i do want to ask you then
terry for for your view on this because
of course there is going to be a reason
he's following bankruptcy and it perhaps
would is it to make him further
judgement proof from millions of dollars
of damages
mike that's exactly what he's trying to
do to make him judgment proof but it's
really good that the judge said no you
can't do that and he is doing all that
he can to get out of this case and to
make sure that around the country in
connecticut in texas that no one can
reach him or his assets but i think he's
going to fail in that endeavor yeah and
again there's three more two more cases
on top of this one three total some 150
million dollars at stake here in damages
being claimed by the victims
families now i want to go to florida a
woman who was retried in the 2014 murder
for hire death of fsu professor dan
markell that that woman's been sentenced
for her role in his shooting eight years
ago markel was gunned down behind the
wheel of his car as he pulled into his
driveway at his tallahassee home
according to the autopsy he was shot
twice at intermediate range
investigators say catherine magbonwa was
the point person in the murder for
higher plot she and sigfredo garcia were
both tried in october 2019. garcia was
found guilty while magbon was resulted
in a mistrial magbonwa was retried in
may and found guilty of first degree
murder conspiracy to commit murder and
solicitation to commit murder a third
person was arrested earlier this year in
the murder for hire plot against markel
his former brother-in-law charlie
adelson now he could go to trial in
early 2023 shortly before his death
markel and ex-wife wendy adelson had
been going through a heated custody
battle there's been speculation of
whether or not she was also involved in
her ex-postman's murder though she's
never been charged and she testified at
both trials magbonwa was sentenced on
her on friday for her involvement
uh in the state of florida versus
catherine magbano on count one which is
the count of first-degree murder you
have been found guilty by a jury you
will be adjudicated guilty and you will
be sentenced to life in prison with no
eligibility for probation or parole
on count two
which is the conspiracy to commit murder
you have been found guilty by a jury you
will be adjudicated guilty and you will
be sentenced to a consecutive sentence
of 30 years in the department of
corrections
on count three the solicitation to
commit murder you have been found guilty
by a jury of that count you are
adjudicated guilty and you will be
sentenced to a consecutive sentence of
30 years in the department of
corrections
coming up on lawn crime daily week three
of the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial begins plus the bench trial
of rebecca rood finally comes to a close
as a missouri judge hands down a verdict
a missouri judge hands down a verdict in
the rebecca rude murder case nearly a
month after the bench trial ended rude
was charged with the murder in the 2017
death of her daughter savannah the 16
year old who had special needs had
previously been adopted as a baby years
later when she began struggling with
behavioral problems as a teen savannah
moved back in with her biological mother
rude and her boyfriend robert pete after
just 11 months with her birth mom she
was reported missing prosecutors alleged
rude abused savannah and that she and
pete eventually killed her and burned
her body
on friday after four weeks of
deliberating the judge handed down the
verdict finding rude not guilty of
first-degree murder or second-degree
murder not guilty of abuse or neglect of
a child and not guilty of tampering with
physical evidence he did find her guilty
however of abandonment of a corpse which
carries a sentence of two to four years
in prison the judge set a sentencing
date for september 15th rude has been in
jail since august of 2017. the time she
has already served will likely be
counted as a part of her sentence kirk
the judge indicated he would have have a
verdict ready weeks before it was
finally handed down so what could have
been the hold up
about this all and was it the correct
verdict
well this is only speculation because
the judge did not release a written
decision but one can only guess that he
struggled with uh determining whether
the prosecution met its burden of
proving guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
which he felt that it did not you know
this is why defendants will often opt
for a bench trial where the judge acts
as finder effect because a judge is
going to be uh dispassionate and weigh
the facts also it's very interesting the
judge was due to retire on july 31st
just you know a couple days uh or a day
or two after releasing the verdict so
one wonders did he want to ensure that
he got it right and that his conscience
was clear as he retired from the bench
or perhaps he just dropped the case and
walked away and avoided the blowback
that might have come from it but terry
based on the verdict did rude make the
correct choice in electing for a bench
trial over a jury trial
absolutely rude made the correct choice
you know when you choose the judge
versus a jury you do it because the law
is going to be in your favor and here
the law was in their favor frankly and
the facts were not i am shocked by the
verdict however because the facts were
really heavily against rebecca rood
there were no other explanations for
what occurred there was no other
defendant they could point to and the
child was in her custody and care when
the death occurred so i'm really shocked
that the judge found the way he did and
as kirk said there was no written
opinion there was just the decision
basically not guilty beyond a reasonable
doubt on most of the counts except that
last count which was a very small
you know misdemeanor terry kirk thank
you for your comments there when we come
back the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial investigators reveal what
the defendant searched for in the days
before the massacre
welcome back as the parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial enters week
three the defense motions to exclude the
shooter's conviction in relation to a
jail battery incident
last week jurors heard testimony from a
broward county sheriff's deputy who was
attacked by the defendant in november
2018. surveillance video of the fight
was also shown in court on monday the
defendant's attorneys argued the jail
incident did not threaten the life of
the sheriff's deputy crews assaulted and
it should be precluded as an aggravating
factor all this comes as part of the
shooter's penalty phase trial for the
mass shooting at marjory stoneman
douglas high school the shooter pleaded
guilty last october to 17 counts of
murder and 17 more counts of attempted
murder for the massacre jurors will now
decide whether he receives life in
prison or the death penalty on monday
jurors heard more about the defendant's
internet search history leading up to
the shooting
february 11th 2018 10 45 and 38 seconds
in the morning the ar-15 google search
goes back to the videos link
then february 11 2018
at 1 45 and 39 seconds in the afternoon
a
youtube search for virginia tech
massacre was conducted virginia tech
massacre was a mass shooting that
occurred in 2000 in
[Music]
where 32 people were shot and killed
then again on february 11th 2018 at 1 45
and 44 seconds in the afternoon
the virginia tech massacre on youtube
on february 11
at
2 12 and 9 seconds in the afternoon
columbine diary youtube search columbine
was a school shooting that occurred in
where 13 people were shot and killed
and those were searches just three days
before the shooting at marjory stoneman
douglas high school now kirk we saw
another example on monday of a victim's
parent breaking down in the gallery how
could these reactions affect this jury
well you know certainly as a parent when
i watch uh you know this these parents
anguish of having their loved ones and
their children rip from them
and for the people who are not parents
it's just very riveting to watch and it
certainly has an effect on the jury
victim uh impact statements always do we
want to suffer the loss but in this
particular case coupled with the
information of these premeditated acts
and all the planning and so forth i
think it's certainly going to have an
impact on the jury uh how could it not
it's just heart-wrenching to watch uh
the testimony of these parents yeah it
makes you ask also whether when they're
considering life or death for nicolas
cruz whether such a penalty of death for
him would deter future shooters whether
it be just pure retributive justice
being put forward by the by the jury as
well these are weighty questions to
consider when talking about the death
penalty in america not least in florida
now terry should the jail fight video
that we talked we talked about before
and testimony about it be excluded or
should it have been will should it be
excluded as the aggravating factor
oh i definitely think it should be
included as an aggravating factor mike
there's no question that it is in this
situation look he had a
large fight with that guard it was very
violent he attacked him he threw him on
the ground he took the taser he could
have seriously injured the guard was
very lucky that he wasn't injured more
seriously just because he wasn't doesn't
mean it's not an aggravating factor i
think that jury needs to see and to
understand that this individual is
dangerous that he's got these previous
capital convictions that this is
something that he should be penalized
for and it should be one of those
factors that goes into whether or not he
gets life or death
terry kirk thank you very much for
joining us here today and thank you
everyone watching for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you